the defi Nanos is quiet Compact and it's
built for many ITX water cooled systems
just like this one but watch out if you
get one Josh might just show up at your
house
randomly fractal designed Define nano s
is small quiet and built for many ITF
water cooled systems just like this one
but if you get one watch out cuz fractal
Josh might just show up at any minute
you know Kyle's full of
[__] well that was immersive yeah is
still not here yet we've been here for
like an hour dude let's get the hell out
of here screw
it excellent the Nvidia GeForce GTX 1060
has launched this is the founders
Edition which you can buy for $300 MSRP
or we are told that there will also be
$250 MSRP third party designs but let's
be honest we were told that with the GTX
1080 and 1070 as well so fool me once in
video
shame that's a shame anyway though uh
the questions I have for this card are
how does it compare to the rx480
recently launched by AMD Radeon will any
of these cards actually sell for $250 or
will they all be priced closer to the
$300 Founders Edition and is this shroud
supposed to look like the Millennium
Falcon or Batman or Optimus Prime or
maybe like a cyber
Pac-Man okay so people usually love or
hate the reference card design design or
Founders Edition as they are now called
by Nvidia personally though I think this
one actually looks pretty nice consider
that at a lower price you'll often get a
less impressive cooler on thirdparty
design graphics cards so this being a
dual slot closed design cooler with a
blower style fan green LED lit GeForce
GTX logo and having a black and silver
shroud made of cast aluminum gives it a
pretty nice premium feel so perhaps more
of a relative value here than with the
1080 and 1070 Founders editions that
have to go up against the very highest
end third party designs there is no back
plate unfortunately that will definitely
be a value ad for custom third party
cards the PCB itself is just shy of 7 in
Long about 175 mm so we've already been
seeing really tiny versions of this card
from thirdparty add and board
manufacturers with the Shroud and the
blower it's just under 10 in Long total
about 250 mm a six pin PCI Express power
connector is located at the end of the
Shroud rather than where the PCB ends
which is actually pretty nice for cable
management and an unobstructed view of
the GeForce GTX logo and Nvidia says
this card has a 120 wat TDP at the heart
of the card is the new Pascal GPU the GP
106 little brother to the GP 104 used in
the 1080 and 1070 it's still 60 nanm
Pascal architecture though with 4.4
billion transistors paired with 6 GB of
192bit gddr5 memory at 8,000 MHz
effective clock speed 10 streaming
multiprocessors 1,280 Cuda cores 80
texture units 192 GB per second of
memory bandwidth and 48 RS round out the
specs since this is a pascal GPU you
also get to take advantage of new Pascal
Technologies including simultaneous
multi-projection for more on those check
out my GTX 1080 intro video which I'll
link right up there no SLI bridge on
this card means no traditional SLI
support not even two-way which I'm kind
of on the fence about I never really
recommended two-way SLI configs in the
past with 60 series cards like the GTX
660 or 960 but I don't like having
options removed from the consumer either
you could still use direct X12 LDA
explicit mode to pair up a couple 1060s
or MDA mode to add other non1 60 or non
envidia cards even with multi-adapter
but that would also require a
well-designed direct X12 title that
properly leverages and balances
multi-gpu usage which in my opinion just
doesn't really exist right now anyway
though I will be discussing directx12
and Vulcan more in depth in another
video once the dust from this launch
settles video outs are three display
port 1.4s one HDMI 2.0b and one DVI just
like the 1080 and 1070 on to
overclocking though my Founders Edition
card had a lot of over clocking Headroom
so expect to see some nicely Factory
overclocked third party designs I used
EVGA Precision X and I ended up tacking
190 MHz onto the GPU clock 250 MHz onto
the memory clock with power Temp and
voltage sliders maxed out at stock the
card has a base clock of 1506 boost of
1709 Max of 1911 and an average of 1835
with the overclock that jumped up to
1681 base 1884 boost 275 Max and 237 MHz
average speed Under full gaming load
temperatures were pretty reasonable with
the founders Edition 1060 if you compare
it to the founders Edition 1080 or 1070
it hit 72° C at stock with fan speed
ranging from 30 to 50% with the
overclock I set the fan manually to 70%
and it hit 75° C Max underload here's
fan noise testing so you can hear for
yourself we're going to start off at
idle here's 40% fan speed typical at
stock settings while gaming
here's 70% which is what I had it set to
while I was
overclocking and here's 100% which you
can use to annoy your
roommates moving on to benchmarks I
tested at 1920 x 1080 and 2560 X 1440
and since it is always controversial
whether or not I use overclocked numbers
I have both stock and overclock numbers
for the GTX 1060 as well as the rx480
AMD radon's closest competing card I
also re benched the GTX 970 so you can
compare nvidia's former best card in
this range and here are my results
[Music]
so clearly the GTX 1060 is faster than
the rx480 but it also costs more there's
also the direct X12 and Vulcan questions
to be answered as these new apis have
asynchronous compute support which
Nvidia still lacks Hardware acceleration
for I wanted to focus today's video more
on currently playable titles however so
I will be following up in the future
with a dedicated video to direct X12
Vulcan and asynchronous compute
hopefully with more info and further
developments in that area finally some
power draw results and please take these
with a grain of salt as I'm recording
Peak wattage which isn't always
consistent remember also that TDP which
is 120 watts for the GTX 1060 and 150
watts for the rx480 refers to how much
heat needs to be dissipated by the
cooler not how much power the card
actually draws so I think what I'm
actually going to do for anyone who
wants more info on the power draw at
least is link to the inevitable PC
perspective review down below because
they have much better power draw testing
equipment than I do so check that down
in the description okay it's conclusion
time once again and I think we can sum
up the GTX 1060 thusly Nvidia knows how
this card performs so they've priced it
accordingly to be more accurate it's
about 5 to 20% faster than an rx480
depending on the test and the settings
of course and for $300 it's 25% more
expensive than the $240 8 gig version of
the rx480 so again Nvidia has the faster
option AMD Radeon appears to have the
better cost to Performance card if
you're upgrading yes this is a very nice
step up from the GTX 970 for a lower
price if you're considering the 1060
versus the 480 right now I think it just
comes down to budget and we're going to
have to wait to see if in the coming
months advances in directx12 and Vulcan
titles show radon gaining a significant
Edge in async compute performance or if
the 8 gig versus 6 gig gig frame buffer
has an impact at higher resolutions but
basically if you're going to spend $200
to $250 get the rx480 if you're going to
spend 250 to 300 get the 1060 lastly
pricing and availability are important
those were issues with the 1070 and 1080
launches so I'm going to be keeping an
eye on nvidia's stock levels for this
card after launch and I think pricing
criticism is well warranted too with the
new and more expensive Founders edition
versus the old style of creating a
reference design that actually sells for
the base price I for one I'm not going
to be talking about a $250 GTX 1060
until I actually see one for sale and in
stock somewhere since the $600 GTX 1080
MSRP still seems to be kind of a
mythical unicorn that you only hear
about in legends of PC gaming
[Music]
past I'd love to hear what you guys
think of this card though so leave me
your comments in the comment section
down below do you guys like this
Founders Edition design for the GT TX
1060 are you all going to be waiting for
add-in board partner models links to
this card on Amazon as well as my Paul's
Hardware store where you can buy shirts
like this one are in the description to
hit the like button and get subscribed
if you enjoyed and as always thank you
very much for watching my videos